what do you see
the rest of the year looking like after
after bending the butcher [ __ ]
man ain't no telling bro you know
telling i got more sessions lined up
you know some r b stuff some pop stuff
who do you want to work with bro
whoever want to work with me [ __ ] and
who really serious about making music
but i'm saying like who do you want to
work with like who are you a fan of that
you haven't worked with yet
man i can't call it i mean [ __ ] bro like
[ __ ] i want to do an album for
kendrick lamar you know i'm saying i
want to do an album for [ __ ] jay-z
i want to do an album for plenty of
people but it's like you know i already
work with these people too but
if i can get an album with kendrick i'll
get an album with jay-z like you know
that'd be lovely
or even even yo i know kendrick was just
shooting a music video
i seen that i know he about you know
he's about to melt the whole
game he's about to go on one of them
then 12 months runs and then just
disappear for three more years
what about on some pop [ __ ] like i think
like i feel like you and post would make
some fire [ __ ] like
for sure like i said man whoever opened
the work really serious about music man